dall'altro i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo ios anno fa vj oggi siamo
su un gioco che mi chiedete di portare
da un sacco di tempo e che finalmente mi
sono deciso di contare che è the sims
ma siccome non sono tanto esperto di the
sims perché ogni volta che faccio racing
faccio sempre casino ho deciso di
chiamare una persona che mi dà una mano
e abbiamo qui con noi oggi devi farmi un
po di spazio però così sono io sono io
perché lui sa ha bisogno di me per
giocare a questo gioco
proprio così allora sabrina e massima
esperta di the sims ha fatto la laurea
su the sims the whale ha due lauree
condivisibili sono contento adesso noi
facciamo una famiglia nel senso di
entriamo nel gioco nel gioco ogni giorno
noi creiamo la famiglia a sasha stai
tranquillo si parte
cosa faccio alla volta che hai tutte le
stanze o tutte le espansioni si blaine
play play giocano blair commessi gioca
devi far vivere le persone perché quel
caso così prima bisogna creare fa vj e
poi che bisogna mettere il personaggio
nudo no no no dedicherà in aria o
un'intimità bisogna andare nel corpo il
corpo a famigliari è così rava se quei
metodi rosso poi metterò sospetta così
anche ma perché essere avatar
va bene è chiaro ok andiamo primato
sulla faccia non c'entra niente con
quello che tu mi ma nulla abbiamo i
capelli così entriamo in quadri capelli
se ci sono i miei me ne vado ecco ecco
questo qua è più o meno coli fianco
napoli conosciamo questo quello che ora
potrà siete soldo casta non la so iniziò
così a casa dice così caso blahnik shock
fosse ancora un paio di più poi più che
sicuro prova no più chiaro qualcuno
inizia a prendere forma
scegliamo gli orecchini le sopracciglia
l'unica roba che cit che c'azzecca
no c'è un po più grande ancora più
grosso al di là in mezzo ragazzi
apprezzate le mie guance mentre sabina
fa questa cosa guarda gli zigomi da
modello ti ho messo gli zigomi
bello mi sembra che contento di queste
cose però cliccare un attimo ma sono
belle ma tieni miccoli a guardarle
appena capito come sarebbe un reggiseno
o quando vai a giocare falso non gioco
genitori quando vai a letto tutti
metterei nudo a letto io dormo nudo
quindi lei senza con le mutande però
almeno quelle no no no no no così bello
la festa non ci pensava proprio perché
tu sarai vestita hot dog
cosa devo dirti a parte che voglio
morire al dog di colori verso ketchup
grazia quando va in piscina piace magari
ti mettono mutandina così fai vedere si
sono già tre tvbox ok ma c'è qualcuno
più ti da perna leopardato no stai aiuti
breve state no non ci penserebbe
d'estate cambiamo st maglietta marron
orribile siamo un po sì va bene ma in
piccole rate per il culo inverno ti
mettiamo il bombay loro ce l'hanno
aspettato cielo questo cielo con questo
cielo questo cielo uguale uguale te lo
giuro aspetta aspetta lo prendo signori
incredibile ma guarda identico noi
vuoi lavorare il quale robe blu qua
paese siamo incredibilmente uguale
allora adesso però dobbiamo fare una
cosa bisogna scegliere un'aspirazione ai
soldi no non so libriamo isolare i soldi
sono ricchezza ricreano la mettiamo
anche su altre volte no perché tu che
non hai sentimenti almeno in the sims
puoi essere uno con i sentimenti per la
voce come sono i soldi allora amore vuoi
essere un romantico seriale o trovare
l'anima gemella
dipende quanto devo spendere l'anima
gemella si ragazzi abbiamo fatto una
modifica il personaggio giusto per
renderlo un po più libero allora idea
che siamo pronti per iniziare a giocare
la nostra va bene ok da solo nona fermo
poi creiamo dove vogliamo
ad abitare allora per me qua qua qua ti
prego no che schivando formulate
piacciono i cani giusto però le tombe
non abbiamo le espansioni che per i cani
sono i parchi
quindi io direi che c'è anche la clinica
veterinaria quindi esposta male il tuo
cane inoltrarlo questa questa mi piace
abbiamo i soldi se con 200.000 dollari
allora facciamo i video forza allora
stiamo investendo e ragazzi super
youtuber quest'anno ad ora ci siamo
perché stiamo mettendo i soldi
semplicemente perché sennò poi non
riusciamo a fare una mazza quindi
carbonatici mamma mia come si fattura
basta con i soldi un cacciatore tanti
soldi
bene bene bene o un milione di sim o
leon allora ragazzi va bene a casa che
vuoi compriamo la cosa che voglio ok
usciamo champ gioca sotto la pioggia ora
come contento che ci hai soldi guarda lo
guardavo questo ballo partiti ma io
voglio sguazzare nel denaro è pronto
sono pronto allora trasferisci quinta
familiare se questi stadi segugio dai
tre scali tema acqua ci vivono 77
persone ne va bene per tu da solo uno è
bellissimo era una casa tutta per sempre
giocare a nascondino ma andiamo a vedere
ok meraviglioso anche le tratto testa di
segugio piacere ma magari resta in testa
di seguito mi piace un sacco
allora testa di segugio j la famiglia
gen ma andiamo a visionare un po la
nostra casa allora quanto sono sono
contento che soprattutto questo di
segugio che messe 22 milioni schifo
milioni di soldi va beh ma giusto questo
cielo fuori da casa vuoi dire bellissimo
e poi andarci anche a pescare se vuoi
bisogni
ora se tutto verde vuol dire che non hai
bisogno
niente ok neanche di rifiutare ma che
cipro stai bene con te perché perché se
ho bisogno di fruttare di ricevere per
ogni fare tutto però io voglio una donna
atti volevo dirti non è che possiamo
creare tu avrai una donna che vorresti
avere nella vita chi non puoi avere se
lei si chiama qua cosi a conquistiamo
qua creiamo selena gomez ha in un me la
vado a rimontare invernale o la crema
coinquilina che il gioco ben o devi
riuscire a proprio lei questa mattina in
famiglia infiliamo la sabrina
tu sei troppo miscredente nei confroti
adesso ti faccio vedere come si
conquista una donna signori questa primo
episodio the sims facciamo vedere come
si conquista una ragazza come fa vj e
riesce ad approcciare a chi manda fuori
case study segugio certe parte primi due
volte sulla colate arrivo guarda che
arriva il tap è tanto contenta tutta
contenta per forza i 2 milioni di
dollari giachino sarà di traverso per le
siano 200 euro grava che sempre ieri la
prima cosa lei cosa fa ma suonare guarda
la tv coi cani cioè non guidate a farli
j deve andare da lei cosa devo fare
sospetto tra l'inizio di lei
se adesso scelgo fermo entusiasmanti
della nuova serie tv ok questa
entusiasmante
ciao selena come sai l'hai visto 13
hanno fatto un po schifo anno aspetterei
prodotto to me era bello bello
la frutto neri e si si si fa così come
si fa così farle i complimenti
complimenti per la serie bella la serie
tv
lorenzo prima che sale nei segni ruota
senza vestiti con profile trovata senza
le city con lorenzo storia come
possibile ma mai dire mai ma no core ma
verame ma no aspetta aspetta ferma non
guardare se l'erano guardare regole non
sono ancora girato
beh
signori sta succedendo rope cosa siamo e
siamo il nuovo modo di fare l'amore
qualcosa succedendo ciao senti ma perché
state parlando così tranquillamente
siete nudi siete nudi nella divertente
che avrebbe la piega nulla io sono
allibito da questa cosa intanto se ne
impara l'abilità di comicità e tu niente
nella serie vai a vedere la televisione
ma perché sta facendo battute sul mio
birillo non so non lasciarla sola chi
non nascerebbe selena non solo da
guardare la tv nudo ma che cosa è questa
a vestiti a merda in piedi poi non
ragazzi sta famiglia incredibile la
famiglia con cui li nargi questa roba
qua lei almeno si veste ma che le vuole
garantita visto contenuta hai fatto con
i colori serve tra poco barral cosa
succederà io non ho capito cosa sta
succedendo i fidati che sarà quello
perché sono nudi ho la sensazione ma non
si sa non ci siamo mai da tina con bacio
niente non abbiamo portato però siamo
nudi a guardare la tv cos'è cos'è
ragazzi più solida quando avete finito
chiamami perché mi sento un po perche
stanno facendo questa cosa perché lo
scultoreo c'è guarda che roba scorso
guarda ragazze normali e se non so che
sarò anch'io cioè non so cosa dire ma
perché ma perché nudi sovrano film non
lo so devi livello che state guardando
la vita di ma cosa state complimento
sincero
piacciono i tuoi bambini come oggi
comodini occhiali ed i tuoi occhiali
piace la pattuglia della ragazza vista
rimorchiando su the sims
io non so perché siamo nudi non lo
capisco ma come si fa a vestirsi non
sono pochi non so come ho fatto a
togliermi i vestiti io dire i ragazzi di
chiuderla qua perché meglio così e ne
generata mi sembrano episodi di american
pie ero intenzionato a fare queste
volevo conquistare pian piano per
arrivare un bacino quel banchetto poi è
poi abbracciarci insomma noi invece non
siamo nudi a mangiare la torta guardare
la tv o a chiacchierare
non so come sia stato possibile pastrano
però non siamo fidanzati di niente
quindi nel prossimo episodio cercheremo
di approcciare seriamente sereno però
che vi sia piaciuto tocco giornate mi
piace che licenziare se lo sapessi
iscrivetevi scegliamo come sempre un
prossimo video però ragazzi
[Musica]